le score
lui
[Musique]
les cherry pour le moment on est dans
disney ils ont tous pas pour la plupart
ils ont voulu faire du disney est resté
jusqu'à la fin de cette séquence car la
dernière personne qui va arriver
elle m'a fait beaucoup de peine on
commence avec maxime gagné qui va mettre
le saut avec une chanson du livre de la
jungle c'est le déguisement le plus
tenace du monde en fait on a une blanche
neige qu'elle a elle est avec nous je
vous demande d'accueillir à gâteaux pour
jour mon prince viendra
un jour seulement
sacha 2
on enchaîne avec un duo qui va vous
interpréter ce rêve bleu ce rêve
[Musique]
c'est un nouveau monde en couleurs où
personne ne nous dit c'est être interdit
de croire encore au bonheur isabelle âge
isabelle et gilles qui vont nous
transporter au pays de mary poppins
non
vous me dites que la reine des neiges et
marais est bien la reine des neiges à
coups de pelle c'est pas un coup de
pelle qu'elle a pris là c'est toute la
pelleteuse
évincé les stalles tous morts dans la
nuit genève
espace où tout le royaume de solitude
ma place qui ont toujours le vent
oh oui
moi par ce biais de ma
l'aliment danseurs qui ce musée en vain
laroche se battre est très très très de
la baja manquer tandis qu applaudir
libéral
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]